[Music]
educators have long wrestled with the
question
how should schools teach the american
story there's certainly truth to claims
that schools long gave short shrift to
people and perspectives that didn't fit
the classic
generals and presidents approach to
history but efforts to course correct
have frequently yielded skewed
narratives that seem intent on turning
america's rich remarkable history into a
litany of cartoonish villainy there's a
need
to more fully capture the breadth of
american history
and to honestly confront our
shortcomings but spiteful caricatures
are no improvement
on whitewashed heroics schools have a
responsibility to teach students the
ideals
of liberty freedom and equality upon
which our country was founded
and to teach them about the times that
our nation has failed to live up to
those ideals
this is the kind of education that helps
youth grasp
the realities of democracy the
responsibilities that accompany freedom
and what it means for citizens to
jointly work
in pursuit of a more perfect union
do you think schools today teach an
accurate view of american history
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to like and
subscribe
for more research and videos from aei